Christopher Lee is most familiar to the
wells, is a consummate actor with a deep,
rich voice and a towering
presence in 1,000 studios films.
He became the embodiment of
evil inhabiting the character
of Counter Von Dracula
with a sinister charm.
Then breaking the mold.
He went on to play some of the most iconic
characters in cinematic history. Yes.
Who would have known that the great
character actor was a former world war two
RF intelligence officer
and his Nazi hunter,
who had been a witness to unspeakable
atrocities. In this week's biographics,
we piss the seller Lloyd to
discover the Real Christopher Lee
Christopher Frank.
Karen Deany.
Lee was born on May the 27th
of 1922 in Belgravia in London.
His father Jeffrey,
was a hero of the first world war having
been decorated for gallantry at the
battle of the Somme.
At the time of his son's bath,
he was a left colonel on
the kings royal rifle court.
Jeffrey was married to an Italian
countess by the name of Sdl Marie.
Blessed with great beauty.
Estelle's heritage traced all the way
back to Emperor Charlemagne as a result of
the household was frequently visitors
by high ranking figures of European
nobility and as the young Christopher
that came into contact with some very
interesting and important people.
Christopher was the second child's where
the sisters Zandra having been born in
1917 however,
the marriage,
it was not a happy one and it's when
the boy was just four years old.
His parents separated
for the next two years.
The children lived with our
style and Wengen Switzerland.
While father remained in the
Belgravia house often two years,
the marriage officially ended.
One in Switzerland are still enrolled.
Her son in a preschool
called Miss Fisher's academy,
which was located in terror attacks.
It was here that Christopher was given
his first acting role appearing as the
lead character in the
play Rumpelstiltskin.
In 1928 a stolen the
children returned to England.
Christopher was put into Agnes
private school in Queen's gate.
London in 1929 is still married a
banker by the name of hardcore George,
Syncrude.
Rose Lee's step father happens to be
the uncle of a young writer named Ian
Fleming who would go on to create
not only James Bonds but also bonds,
arch nemesis,
scaramanga or the man with the golden
gun who would the would famously play on
film a half century later
following the marriage,
the family moved to full
on at the age of nine,
Christopher was enrolled at summer fields,
a boarding school in Oxford.
They enjoyed his time at some airfields
and quickly made friends and proved
himself to be a gifted
and studious people.
Among his closest friends at summer
fields was Patrick McNee who would also
carve a career as an axa and
find fame as secret agents.
John Steed in the Avengers,
the ends,
McKinney both enjoyed acting and
it appeared in a number of school.
Plays together some of the fields once
a feeding school to Eton College and in
1935 Christopher sent the scholarship
exam and was interviewed by the school.
How are they as math disability let him
down and he missed out on a scholarship
by one place. If he was to attend eaten,
his family would have to pay his way.
Despite his mother's urgings, his
stepfather was unwilling to foot the bill,
so I ended up at Wellington College
in Berkshire. It was at Wellington.
There's lead proved himself to be a
brilliant linguist. He mastered French,
Spanish, Italian, and German,
and he's gained a passing
knowledge of Swedish, Greek,
and Russian.
Yet despite his academic prowess,
he chafed under the harsh discipline
that was meted out at the school.
He hated the irregular parades and
weapons training that became more and more
regular as talk of war became more
frequent in political circles.
So it was with some relief that he had
to leave Wellington when his stepfather
went bankrupt in 1939
the 17 year old's education was over.
It was now expected to make
his own way in the worlds,
but he entered the job markets just as
the summer holidays were beginning and
they wouldn't know prospects.
After a month of fruitless job hunting,
he was allowance to join his sister who
was on holiday on the French Riviera.
While there the heard news that the last
public execution in France was to take
place in Paris along
with thousands of others.
He took the trip to witness the
grease from events from Paris.
He traveled to mentor in Southern France.
There he stayed with an exile
Russian principally family
with ties to his mother.
He enjoyed his time
there and wanted to stay,
but with Europe about
to erupt into warfare.
It was decided that it would be better
off back in the relative safety of London
for a short time. He worked as a
clinic and a shipping line office.
When war broke out in September of 1939
league was eager to do his part too
young to join the regular army.
He teamed up with some friends
and traveled to Finland
with plans to fight aside
the fins in their struggle against Russia.
The British teens may have
had a lot of fighting spirit,
but none of them knew how to ski,
which rendered them virtually useless
in the snow covered battles terrain.
They were politely thanks for their
assistance and then strongly encouraged to
to returns to England back in London.
Lee resumed his work as an office guy
in 1940 at the age of 18 he joined the
home guard. It was around this
time that his father Jeffrey died,
though we had great respect for
his father's wartime endeavors.
Christopher had no desire to follow his
footsteps into the regular army knowing
that conscription was not far away.
He decided to enter the armed
services on his times. Consequently,
he volunteered to fight
in the Royal Air Force
following his initial training.
They were stations to southern Rhodesia
on the brink of his first solo flying
mission. He complains of
blackouts and blurred vision.
He was diagnosed with a failed optic
nerve and told that he would never fly
again for a number of months.
He was transferred around
the RAF service in Africa,
but given nothing meaningful to do.
Then out of frustration,
he applied to ref intelligence
service gaining entry to the service.
He was posted as a water to the
Salisbury prison in Rhodesia.
From that he was moved to the Suez
Canal zone where he was put to work and
intelligence gathering activities
during the north African campaign.
He was deeply involved as part of number
260 Squadron Raf nearly losing his life
when an airfield was destroyed by a
German bombing rate in the winter of 1943
and he was part of an office swap
and he was succonded to the army.
He spent the next year serving with the
gawkers of the eighth Indian Infantry
Division.
He saw action in the battle
of Monte Cassino almost
losing his life when a plane
crashed on takeoff.
Towards the end of 1944 he was promoted
to flight leftenants and it's posted to
air force HQ when the ends of hostilities
finally came in April of 1945 he was
given a position in the central registry
of war criminals of security suspects.
He had become essentially a Nazi hunter.
Her work was top secret and we have a few
specifics about what he did in a later
interview. However, he did see this.
We were given dossiers of what
they're done and told to find them,
interrogate them as much as we could
then hand them over to the appropriate
authority. We saw these concentration
camps. Some had been cleaned up,
some are not.
They left the army in 1946 after what
he had experienced over the previous few
years. He could no longer bring
himself to work in an office.
You had the opportunity to
teach classics at university,
but didn't fancy that prospect either.
Unsure what to make of
his post military life.
The 24 year old founders himself dining
at the Italian embassy in London with
his cousin, the Italian ambassador
to England, Niccolo Karen Deni.
Also if the Blue Karen
Deni looked at me and said,
have you ever thought of being an actor
taking a little off guard by this?
Be Replies, no way, don't think
so. Karen Deany then replies,
perhaps when you go away you might want
to think about it. Let's think about it.
He did. He decided that he quite likes
the idea and mentioned it to his mother.
The Countess has, however,
was vehemently opposed.
A career in acting was beneath
this status. She implored
and besides it six feet,
five he was too tall.
It was also to foreign looking and
it was hardly a steady line of work,
but the more she railed
against the acting idea,
the more her son became determined
to make a success of it.
Towards the end of 1946 he joins the
rank of company of Youth and the next few
years he busied himself
learning the craft of acting.
He swept to the first stage [inaudible]
prompts cards for the actors on the
stage and eventually got tiny parts
himself. Then came small roles in films.
It's high.
Did indeed work against him with casting
directors struggling to find a place
fan. However, the roles did come.
Director's managed to find creative ways
to hide his height such as having him
sit during his scenes.
Some of his roles in these
early years where and creditors,
while others ended up on
the cutting room floor,
but they all added to the skills that
he would display when the big roles
eventually came around.
In 1957 Lee was hired by hammer film
productions for his biggest part,
yet he was to play the monster
created by Baron von Frankenstein,
who was to be played by his
good friend Peter Cushing.
The movie goals of a castle
of Frankenstein founds any
immediate audience among
the lovers of horror who clamored for
more hammer decided to satisfy the demand
with a cinematic take on the Bram Stoker
Classic Dracula with the d and the lead
role. The movie released in 1958 was
a huge hit within these sinister,
yes charming take on the fanged account
forever embedding itself in the Public
Consciousness Dracula.
That was the movie that
turns the struggling 36 year
old journeyman actor into a
star he laid to recalls. It's
brought me a name, a fan club,
and a secondhand car for
all of which I was grateful.
The Dracula movie was both a
blessing and a curse. Philly.
It's inevitably at typecast him and
tied him to a peer and a succession of
sequels,
each one worse than the last.
When he tried to bring the series
to an ends, he was in his own words,
black males by hammer executives who
would remind him how many people and he
would put out on the street if
the next movie it was not made.
Lee Played The parts of Dracula 10
times and increasingly grew tired of the
shadow that it cost over is Korea.
It took eight years for the
Second Dracula to be released.
By which time the first movie had made
a tremendous impact all over the world.
Yes, when Lee was handed the script
for the SQL, he was horrified,
not spoiling the murderous things
that his character was asked to do,
but by the terrible dialogue that
he had been given. As a result,
he refused to do the lines, which is
why Dracula does not say a single word.
In 1965 is Dracula prince of darkness,
and he was also concerned
that the character of Dracula,
it was getting further and
further away from water.
Bram stoker had in mind
when he wrote the book.
According to the man himself,
Lee's real career as a serious actor
started when he was cast as the mucky to
sad and a tale of two cities in 1958
this was in fact his 43rd movie.
Other the serious roles follows,
but he was unable to escape the
horror genre for over a decade.
Appearing in a slew of largely forgettable
blood and guts flicks both for hammer
studios and other production companies.
In 1962 Leo auditioned for
a role in the World War II.
You classic the longest date.
It is ironic that despite
his distinguished service
for his country during the
actual war,
he was turned down because it was felt
that audiences wouldn't accept him as a
military type from 1965 until 1969 leave,
despite his obvious English bearing
start in a series of movies in which he
played the villainess Oriental Fu Manchu.
His skill as an accident along with long
hours in the makeup chair allows him to
breathe life into the role
of the criminal masterminds.
In 1917 Lee picks up a single day's
work as the narrator in a film about the
market you decide in titled Eugenie.
It was only when the movie was released
that he realized he was appearing in a
soft porn film loaded with sex scenes
that were shot when he wasn't around.
He was embarrassed and he was angry,
but he couldn't really do much about it.
Leed credits his role as Sherlock Holmes
is smarter older brother Minecraft in
the 1970s movie,
the private life of Sherlock Holmes as
the role that allows him to finally break
free from being typecast as the
horror guy. Three years later,
he played Lord Summer Aisle in what is
considered the best movie ever made that
wicker man,
but he was so taken with the book of well
upon which the movie is based that he
offered his services free of charge.
The film has become a cult classic and
it is considered one of the best British
movies ever made in the mid
1970 [inaudible] and Lee
appeared as cob to rush for
in the three musketeers and did sequel.
The four musketeers.
During the fight scene,
he received a knee injury which would
play again for the rest of his life back
in the early sixties Lee's stamp cards
in the in Fleming who had made it big as
an author but offered him the role of
the villainous title character in the
movie adaptation of is James
Bond's novel. Doctor. No.
Lee accepted the role on the spot.
However,
Fleming had and clearly with the producers
and they had already chosen their man.
It doesn't.
Years later,
they finally got his chance when he
landed the role of Francisco Scaramanga in
the 10th bond film,
the man with the Golden Gun,
Lee breathe life into
this character as well,
who Fleming had written as a rather
bland bad guy lacking any real depth.
The writer was delighted
with the portrayal claiming
that Lee had created the
sinister counterpart to James Bond.
Yeah.
By 1977 Lee had established a reputation
as a fine actor who could take on any
role and to make it his own.
Still.
He was concerned that if
he remains in England,
he would eventually be lured back
into the dark tunnel of horror movies.
Avoiding that fate was the
prime motivation for his
move to the United States in
1977 his first American role,
it was a departure from anything that
had gone before the modern day disaster.
Apple 77 the following year,
he went even further beyond his comfort
zone and appeared as the guest host on
NBC live comedy show Saturday night live.
He remembered the experience as the most
terrifying hour and a half of his life
that night though he impressed many
people including budding director Steven
Spielberg, who promptly signed
him up for his next project,
the period comedy in 1941 they had the
chance to follow up with another comedy,
a spoof of airports.
77 gold airplane.
Bowtie turned the role down
and do went to Leslie Nielsen.
Lee would later refer to this decision
as a big mistake through the 1980s and
nineties near peers in a
broad spectrum of movies,
genres from dramas to
comedies and even musicals.
He also made regular appearances on
the small screen for both British and
American television
audiences in 1998 and he was,
controversially is Muhammad Ali Jinnah,
the founder of Pakistan
in the movie Jenna,
it was to be his most demanding role
and the one that carried the most
responsibility for 10 weeks.
He acted the part of the father of the
Pakistani nation on location as thousands
of local scrutinized his every move.
The vast majority of them were
won over by the consummate actor,
amazed and delighted with
his ability to become Gina.
The movie was hugely important to Lee,
but it did not achieve
widespread commercial success.
Leah been a lifelong fan
of the j r r Tolkien,
Lord of the rings series of books,
reading the manually.
He had once actually met talking and for
decades had harbored the desire to play
the role of Gandalf.
What he was offered and immediately
accepted was the part of ceremony in the
trilogy to be directed by New
Zealand director Peter Jackson.
The role of brought him to
a new generation of fans
who were in thrilled with
his commanding performance.
Those who were privileged
to work with him on the set.
We're also captivated by the
Christopher the aura. In one scene,
it Sarah man was to be stabbed in the
back and director Jackson coach lead to
scream as the blade entered his body,
Lee turned to Jackson and asked him if
it ever actually seen a man get stabbed
in the back. Jackson admitted that
he hadn't to which Lee said, well,
I have and I know what to do.
He went on to explain that such
a wound would puncture the lungs,
preventing the person from screening.
Ah,
it's best they would basically lists
out a quiet grown with this revelation.
The set went quiet.
All present,
knew that they were in the presence of
a man who had lived through things that
they could only imagine.
The success of the Lord
of the rings movies led to
Lee's insertion into the star
wars franchise where he plays the evil
counts Dukie throughout the 2000 he also
appeared in a string of Tim Burton movies,
including sleepy hollow and Sweeney to
onto the demon barber of fleet street.
In 2011 Lee embraced his roots by
appearing in his first hammer film in 35
years. The residents along with
Hilary Swank while filming in Mexico,
he suffered a back injury and tap
to undergo surgery. As a result,
he was unable to play a leading role in
the long awaited sequel to the wicked
man entitles the wicker tree.
However,
he wants to time institute appear in the
film and was given a small role as the
mentor of the character
he was meant to play.
Although in his late eighties Lee was
insistent that he had no intentions of
retiring from acting.
He often said that making movies had
never been a job to him. It was his life.
It gave him meaning and it gave him
purpose with respiratory problems and
[inaudible]. He couldn't accept as many
roles as he added in earlier days. Still,
he was kept busy with voiceover work
and his narration work and at least one
major production each year.
His final movie was an independent
production called angels. If nothing hill.
Christopher Lee died on June the seventh
2015 at the age of 93 the official
cause of death was hot fade.
Yeah. In the tributes that float,
he was recognized as a pairing and 208
films more than anyone else in history.
Those myriad roles allow him to live
on enabling has millions of fans,
both old and new to experience the
presence of a true giant of cinema.
So I really hope you enjoyed that
episode of biographics. If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube. If you actually want to
get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that will send
you a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when
we put out a new video. Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always,
thank you for watching.
Yeah.